there's a response to that blog post by
Paul Cristiano there's many responses
but he he makes a few different points
he summarizes the set of agreements he
has with you instead of disagreements
one of the disagreements was that
in a form of a question uh
can AI make Big Technical contributions
and in general expand human knowledge
and understanding and wisdom
as it gets stronger and stronger so AI
in our pursuit of understanding
how to solve the alignment problem as we
March towards strong AGI can can not AI
also help us in solving the alignment
problem so expand our ability to reason
about how to solve the alignment problem
okay
um so that the fundamental difficulty
there is suppose I said to you like well
how about if the AI helps you win the
lottery
bye
trying to guess the winning lottery
numbers
and you tell it how close it is to
getting next week's winning lottery
numbers
and it just like keeps on guessing and
keeps on learning until finally you've
got the winning lottery numbers
well what a way of decomposing problems
is suggestor verifier
not all problems decompose like this
very well but some do
if the problem is
for example like
guessing a plain text guessing a
password that will hash to a particular
hash text
um where like you have what the password
hashes to you don't have the original
password
then if I present you a guess you can
tell very easily whether or not the
guess is correct so verifying a guess is
easy but coming up with a good
suggestion is very hard
and when you can easily tell whether the
AI output is good or bad or how good or
bad it is and you can tell that
accurately and reliably then you can
train an AI to produce outputs that are
better
right and if you can't tell whether the
output is good or bad you cannot train
the AI to produce good to produce better
outputs
so the problem with the lottery ticket
example is that when the AI says well
what if next week's winning lottery
numbers are
dot dot dot dot you're like I don't know
next week's Lottery hasn't happened yet
to train a system to play to win chess
games you have to be able to tell
whether a game has been won or lost
and until you can tell whether it's been
won or lost you can't update the system
yeah
okay uh to push back on that you can in
that's true but there's a difference
between over the board chess in person
and simulated games played by Alpha zero
with itself yeah so is it possible to
have simulated kind of games if you can
tell whether the game has been won or
lost yes so can't you not have this kind
of simulated exploration by weak AGI to
help us humans human in the loop to help
understand how to solve the alignment
problem every incremental step you take
along the way TPT four five six seven as
it takes steps towards this year
so the problem I see is that your
typical human has a great deal of
trouble telling whether I or Paul
Christiano is making more sense
and that's with two humans both of whom
I believe of Paul and claim of myself
are sincerely trying to help neither of
whom is trying to deceive you
I believe of Paul and claim of myself
uh so the deception thing's the problem
for you the manipulation the alien
actress so yeah there's like two levels
of this problem one is that the weak
systems are well there's three levels of
this problem there's like the weak
systems that just don't make any good
suggestions there's like the middle
systems where you can't tell if the
suggestions are good or bad and there's
the strong systems that have learned to
lie to you
can't weak AGI systems
help model lying like what uh is it such
a giant leap
that's
totally non-interpretable for weak
systems can cannot weak systems at scale
with human with uh trained on knowledge
and whatever see whatever the mechanism
required to achieve AGI can't a slightly
weaker version of that be able to with
time
compute time
and simulation
find all the ways that this critical
point uh this critical tribe can go
wrong and model that correctly or no
okay yeah I would love to dance yeah no
no it's it's I'm I'm probably not doing
a great job of explaining
which I can tell because like the uh the
the The Lex system didn't output like ah
I understand so now I'm like trying a
different output to see if I tried
listically like well no different output
I'm being trained to Output things that
make Lex look like he think that he
understood what I'm saying and agree
with me yeah right so this is GPS
talking to gpt3 right here so like uh
help me out here help me
well I like I'm trying I'm trying not to
be like I'm also trying to be
constrained to say things that I think
are true and not just things that get
you to agree with me
yes 100
I think I understand is a beautiful
output of a system genuinely spoken and
I don't I think I understand in part but
you have a lot of intuitions about this
line this gray area between
strong AGI and weak AGI then I'm trying
to
um I mean or or a series of seven
thresholds to Cross or yeah but I mean
you have really deeply thought about
this and explored it and it's
interesting to sneak up to your
intuitions and different from different
from different angles like why is this
such a big leap why is it that we humans
at scale a large number of researchers
doing all kinds of simulations uh you
know prodding the system in all kinds of
different ways together with uh the
assistance of the uh the the weak AGI
systems why can't we build intuitions
about how stuff goes wrong why can't we
do excellent AI alignment Safety
Research okay so like I'll get there but
the one thing I want to note about is
that this has not been remotely how
things have been playing out so far the
capabilities are going like and the
alignment stuff is like crawling like a
tiny little snail in comparison got it
so like if this is your hope for
survival you need the future to be very
different from how things have played
out up to right now
and you're probably trying to slow down
the capability gains because there's
only so much you can speed up that
alignment stuff
but leave that aside we'll mention that
also but maybe in this perfect world
where
uh we can do serious alignment research
humans and AI together
so again the difficulty is what makes
the human say I understand and is it
true is it correct or is it something
that fools the human the when the
verifier is broken
the more powerful suggestor does not
help it just learns to fool the verifier
previously before all hell started to
break loose in the field of artificial
intelligence
there was this person trying to raise
the alarm and saying you know in a sane
world we sure would have a bunch of
physicists working on this problem
before it becomes a giant emergency and
other people being like ah well you know
it's going really slow it's going to be
30 years away and 30 only in 30 years
will you have systems that match the
computational power of human brains so
yeah I started yours off we've got time
and like more sensible people saying if
aliens were Landing in 30 years you
would be preparing right now
but you know leaving and
and the the world looking on at this and
sort of like nodding along and be like
ah yes the people saying that it's like
definitely a long way off because
progress is really slow that sounds
sensible to us
RL HF thumbs up produce more outputs
like that one I agree with this out but
this output is persuasive
even in the field of effective altruism
you quite recently had people publishing
papers about like ah yes well you know
to get something at human level
intelligence it needs to have like this
many parameters and you need to like do
this much training of it with this many
tokens according to these scaling laws
and and at the rate that Moore's Law is
going at the rated software is going
it'll be in 2050
and me going like
what
you don't know any of that stuff
like this is like this one weird model
that is all has all kinds of like
you have done a calculation that does
not obviously bear on reality anyways
and this is like a simple thing to say
but you can also like produce a whole
long paper
like impressively arguing out all the
details of like how you got the number
of parameters and like how you're doing
this impressive huge wrong calculation
and the I think like most of the effect
of altruists
who are like paying attention to this
issue the larger World paying no
attention to it at all
you know or just like nodding along with
the giant impressive paper because you
know you like press thumbs up for the
giant impressive paper and thumbs down
for the person going like I don't think
that this paper Bears any relation to
reality and I do think that we are now
seeing with like gpt4 and the Sparks of
AGI
possibly depending on how you define
that even
uh I I think that EAS would now consider
themselves less convinced by the very
long paper on
the argument from biology as to AGI
being 30 years off
and but you know like this is what
people pressed thumbs up on
and when the and if you train an AI
system to make people press thumbs up
maybe you get these long elaborate
impressive papers arguing for things
that ultimately fail to bind to reality
for example
and it feels to me like I have watched
the field of alignment just fail to
thrive
except for these parts that are doing
these sort of like relatively very
straightforward and legible problems
like
like can you find the like like finding
the induction heads inside the giant
inscrutable matrices like once you find
those you can tell that you found them
you can verify that the discovery is
real
but it's a it's a tiny tiny bit of
progress compared to how fast
capabilities are going once you because
that is where you can tell that the
answers are real and then like outside
of that you have you have cases where it
is like hard for the funding agencies to
tell who is talking nonsense and who's
talking sense and so the entire field
fails to thrive and if you
and if you like give thumbs up to the AI
whenever it can talk a human into
agreeing with what it just said about
alignment
I'm not sure you are training it to
Output sense
because I have seen
the nonsense that has gotten thumbs up
over the years and so so just like maybe
you can just like put me in charge but
I can generalize I can extrapolate I can
be like oh
maybe I'm not infallible either maybe if
you get something that is smart enough
to get me to press thumbs up it has
learned to do that by fooling me and
explaining whatever flaws in myself I am
not aware of
and that ultimately could be summarized
that the verifier is broken when the
verifier is broken the more powerful
suggestor just learns to exploit the the
flaws in the verifier
you don't think it's possible
to build the verifier that's powerful
enough
for
agis that are stronger than the ones who
currently have
so AI systems that are stronger that are
out of the distribution of what we
currently have I think that you will
find great difficulty getting AIS to
help you with anything where you cannot
tell for sure that the AI is right once
the AI tells you what the AI
says is the answer for sure yes but
probabilistically
yeah the the probabilistic stuff is a
giant Wasteland of you know
Eliezer and Paul Cristiano arguing with
each other and EA going like uh
and that's with like two actually
trustworthy systems that are not trying
to deceive you you're talking about the
two humans that's often Paul Cristiano
yeah
yeah those are pretty interesting
systems mortal meat bags
with intellectual capabilities and World
Views interacting with each other
yeah it's just hard if it's hard to tell
who's right and it's hard to train an AI
system to be right
I mean even just the question of who's
manipulating and not you know I have
these conversations on this podcast
and doing a verifier is tough it's a
tough problem even for us humans and
you're saying that tough problem becomes
much more dangerous when the
capabilities of the intelligence system
across from you is growing exponentially
now I'm saying it's
difficult
when it and dangerous in proportion to
how it's alien and how it's smarter than
you
growing up not I would not say growing
exponentially first because the word
exponential is like a thing that has a
particular mathematical meaning and
there's all kinds of like ways for
things to go up that are not exactly on
an exponential curve and I don't know
that it's going to be exponential so I'm
not going to say exponential but like
even leaving that aside this is like not
about how fast it's moving it's about
where it is
how alien is it how much smarter than
you is it